hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
rockstar games have almost
single-handedly revolutionized the world
of gaming titles such as Grand Theft
Auto and Red Dead Redemption sits in the
hearts of many gamers but how did two
brothers who worked at a music label and
knew nothing about programming or game
desire create one of the greatest video
game publishing companies in history in
this video we'll find out Grand Theft
Auto was one of the first titles to
start pushing the boundary of gaming
there were games like Mortal Kombat and
other graphically violent games
available but Grand Theft Auto was
different it was realistic
it had real-world scenarios with video
game consequences on the other hand
games like Mortal Kombat were set in
science fiction and tailored mostly to
gamers Rockstar wanted to make gaming
for everyone they steered away from
sci-fi and in the process made their
games controversial even been banned in
multiple countries and facing
class-action lawsuits but the
controversy only made their games more
popular the Rockstar story starts with
two brothers from London Sam and Dan
Hauser
the brothers have quite the Rockstar
bringing which would later influence the
DNA of their gaming company their mother
was a famous actress
Geraldine Moffat she starred alongside
Michael Caine in the movie Get Carter
which pushed the edges of controversy
with its crime sex and style their
father was a musician who ran the most
popular jazz club in England
here the two brothers often hang out
with famous jazz musicians during the
genres peak in the 1980s Sam came across
something that would change his life
video games when he discovered them he
fell in love with the concept of being
able to transport him to another world
later the brothers discovered something
that would change the perception of the
world it was hip hop their love for
rebellion and hate for civil order was
exactly the outlet that hip hop provided
them for his 18th birthday Sam's dad
took him to New York where he bought
leather jackets and Jordans he would
roam the New York streets as if he was
an East Coast rapper one day Sam
having lunch with his father who was an
executive from the record label BMG he
asked his father why is everyone in the
record business so old why don't he have
young people working there this question
would actually land Sam a job at the
record label it was also this brush
attitude that led both Sam and his
brother to be given the lead of a new
gaming business that the record label
had just purchased but didn't know what
to do with from here they began pushing
the boundaries of video games despite
having no experience in the area in 1997
they would create a top-down driving and
shooting game which would later become
one of the greatest franchises in
history they originally called a race
and chase but settled on the name grand
theft order in 1998 BMG interactive was
purchased by a company called take 2
this led sam dan and two other
executives to move to new york and
create a new subsidiary which they were
call rockstar games the original 2d
versions of GTA did well but it wasn't
until the franchise went to 3d in GTA 3
that the Rockstar studio set themselves
apart
what made Rockstar unique at the time
was the idea of giving gamers complete
freewill
if you wanted you could follow the
storyline and do the mission or if you
earn a more chaotic mood you could roam
the streets freely causing havoc the
open-world is one of the most important
aspects of the game yes it is violent
but the freedom to do bad things take a
joyride or get a burger is what makes
their games great and this is what first
drew me to the GTA series it was just so
much fun to do whatever you wanted in a
fictional world Rockstar was founded
with a mission statement the video games
for the next mass-market entertainment
medium that they were uniquely
interesting and powerful and that we as
a company would serve two masters to
prove this fact combining the production
values of movies with an obsession with
gameplay above all else as rock star
began pioneering the industry with its
adult content they increasingly wanted
to make video games that were cool and
not just for geeks and gamers in 2002
with GTA vice sity that's exactly what
they did
draped in neon vice city was 1980s Miami
here players could live out their own
scarface story and still today is the
44th best selling game of all time
paired with other success like Midnight
Club Max Payne and Red Dead the studio
soon became an industry leader in the
gaming world the brothers were truly
rockstars the studio would keep pushing
the edges of video games in terms of
quality game design and storytelling but
their games would soon bring controversy
they became the main target for
politicians during the impacts of video
game violence on the youth this
controversy ultimately made rockstar
games even more popular people just
wanted what others told them that they
couldn't have in 2004 they would release
grand theft auto san andreas the 21st
best selling game of all time it
features gang warfare across a fictional
combination of Los Angeles San Francisco
and Las Vegas the map was an extensive
open world where missions were optional
allowing players to simply explore and
do what they wanted almost everything
was interactive and customizable the
main character CJ even got fat or built
muscle depending on your activity but
Rockstar knew their limits and even cut
out scenes when they thought it was too
much one scene was an adult interaction
which was cut out but not entirely
removed from the game's code as
untangling it would have taken too many
resources once the game hit PC people
began modifying the code for cheats and
different gameplay conditions soon the
hidden scene was discovered and through
a software patch made playable the scene
dubbed hot coffee would result in
numerous court cases against Rockstar
for its content rating it was previously
rated M but now had to be converted to
adults only the recall of the game cost
twenty five million dollars and the
adults-only rating stopped the game from
being stopped in the majority of stores
as they refused to carry out all rated
content one of the Rockstar brothers Sam
Houser would even be called to Capitol
Hill for a hearing the case would be
settled in 2009 and Rockstar refuses to
ever discuss hot coffee ever again their
bad-boy image fed their popularity this
time however they needed to hit the
brakes
as the years pass from San Andreas
people awaited rock stars next
hyper-violent game so in 2006 they
released table tennis no violence
no story just a simple game to show off
their new game engine but this didn't
mean rockstar was done with their iconic
style
later that year Rockstar would release
bully a game which pits students against
bullies most of the violent scenes for
schoolyard fights their next game
manhunt - was so violent that it
received an adults-only rating and was
effectively banned around the world this
forced rockstar to tone it down in order
to be able to actually sell the game
though for rockstar they could afford
some banning because GTA was their main
cash cow and it was going well and soon
the next GTA would again remind people
what Rockstar could do GTA 4 was focused
around New York's underbelly and there
was another huge success it ranks 24th
on the best-selling games list of all
time the Rockstar advance game engine or
rage was a close source original game
engine that allowed GTA 4 to be an HD
the game cost an estimated 100 million
dollars to produce and Rockstar left no
stone unturned they even hired private
investigators to track down lost
musicians to purchase the rights to
their songs but their biggest game was
yet to come
GTA 5 is still the best-selling game of
all time pushing six billion dollars of
revenue that's more than the top two
highest-grossing Hollywood movies of all
time compliant avatar and Avengers
endgame the first billion in sales came
within the first three days it costs 250
million dollars to make with the
downloadable content providing years of
continuous online gameplay as you could
imagine the game was no small feat it
took a thousand pages of script 8
production studios and months of voice
and motion-capture
they talked to FBI agents experts in the
Mafia and street gangs just to get the
best possible experience for the player
Rockstar had done it again
the map was massive the graphics were
unbelievable at the time and the story
revolved around three main characters
which were interconnected and developed
with the game's progression it was the
culmination of all the great things from
the previous GTA games in a new and
exciting world and just recently
Rockstar released Red Dead Redemption 2
- massive critical and public acclaim
with a sprawling landscape an immersive
story and outstanding graphics where
sometimes he just had to stop playing
and look around all of this had
undoubtedly caused a lot of excitement
for the next GTA game and seeing that
GTA 5 was released nearly six years ago
it surely can't be long now during the
release of Red Dead Redemption - dan
Houser was quoted as being relieved that
the release Red Dead Redemption
- instead of GTA 6 because of the speed
of current cultural shifts as the main
writer for the GTA series Dan said he
was unsure that they would ever do a GTA
6 with America being so polarized
between the left and right he stated
that the extremes of both sides were
beyond parody and people would be angry
with whatever they did he goes on to say
that if the game was released today
we'll be out of date within two minutes
this suggests that the new GTA would be
set in a different time some rumors
point to the return of the 1980s in a
vice sity world regardless fans are
excited and so am i however while there
hasn't been an announcement for GTA 6
you can bet that rockstar is working on
it it's claimed there's a new GTA will
arrive on next generation gaming
consoles due to the performance and size
requirements GTA 6 is rumored to be the
biggest GTA Rockstar have ever tried
their hands at
a company that's committed to giving
consumers complete freedom of choice has
become something that's ever rarer as
time passes but it's worked out for the
house of brothers and their company
Rockstar from their affluent but
rebellious beginnings
they've revolutionized gaming forever
freedom
combined with the best high-quality game
design and immersive story Alliance fit
for a Hollywood movie have made rockstar
games second to none for the brothers
it's just about perfecting a craft and
making a good product dan Houser speaks
quote our goal as a company isn't for
people to say that rockstar has got a
good game design but bad stories or good
stories and bad game design we want them
to say Rockstar makes good games it's up
to us to make the best stuff we can make
it's not necessarily up to us to shout
from the rooftops about how clever we
are how progressive we are or how
sophisticated we are it's our place to
make stuff that's as good as it can be
and I think that's an important lesson
for everyone if you are in the business
of making something do the best that you
can
so that wraps up our look at rockstar
games let me know what your favorite
rockstar game is in the comments section
below
and what are you excited for in GTA 6 if
you do want to see the actual origins of
video games I've got a video that you
can click on coming right up after this
anyway this has been to gogo and you've
been watching cold fusion thanks for
watching and I'll catch you again soon
for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]